The following
content is provided
under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
education resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Starting
today on section 1.3,
actually we'll
finish that today.
And that's about the big problem
in, or the most common problem
in scientific computing,
solving a linear system.
Au=b.
How would you do that?
So we will certainly do
it for some examples.
Like our free-fixed or
our fixed-fixed matrices.
But I thought I'd just
put some comments.
Often I make comments that go
beyond what specific things
we will do in detail.
Certainly the
workhorse of-- if I'm
in MATLAB notation, the
workhorse would be backslash.
That command is the
quick, natural way
to get the answer u.
And I want to say
more about backslash.
I won't be able to say
all the things it does.
There's a lot built
into that command.
And the MATLAB
helpdesk would give
the details of all
the different things
that backslash actually does.
It looks first, can it divide
the problem into blocks,
into smaller problems.
It looks to see
if A is symmetric.
If it's symmetric,
because of course,
that would cut the work
in half because you
know half the matrix
from the other half
in the symmetric case.
It goes hopefully
along and eventually
gives you the answer.
Okay, so I'm going to
say more about that.
Because that's by elimination.
The method there is elimination.
I just thought I would mention
that if I had a large sparse
matrix, so I was in sparse
math MATLAB and used backslash,
it would try to
reorder the rows.
Or it will try to reorder
the rows in an optimal way.
Now, what would
be an optimal way?
Just so you have
an idea of what.
So elimination takes
this matrix, right?
It's got all its rows.
And we'll do examples.
So the idea of elimination
is that it produces a zero.
So let's suppose it accepts
the first row as the pivot row.
And this (1, 1) entry
would be the pivot.
And then how does
it use the pivot?
It subtracts multiples of that
pivot row from the other rows
in order to get zeroes
in the first column.
So then it has a
new matrix that's
like it's one size smaller.
And then it just
continues all the way
until it gets to a
triangular matrix
with all the pivots sitting
there on the diagonal.
So that's the idea
of elimination.
And we'll do small examples.
So why would you want
to reorder the rows?
Two reason, two good reasons
for reordering the rows.
One reason which
MATLAB will always do,
unless it has some
good reason not to,
is if that pivot is too small
compared to numbers below it
it will pick the largest and
reorder to put the largest
pivot up there.
So you like large pivots.
Why do you like large pivots?
Because for numerical
stability that
gives you small multipliers.
If this is the biggest number
then all the multiples that you
need, the multiple
of that row that you
want to subtract from the other
rows will be less than one.
The multiplier is, so
just let's remember,
the multiplier is the entry to
eliminate divided by the pivot.
So if that entry
to be eliminated
is smaller then the pivot, then
the multiplier's less than one
and things stay stable.
So that's a picture
of elimination,
a sort of first picture.
And if it's sparse that means
there's a lot of zeroes.
And where would we like
those zeroes to be?
Where would we
like to find zeroes
to save time and use
to avoid all the steps,
to avoid going
through every step.
If this was already a
zero then it's there
and we don't need
to get it there.
The job is already done.
We can go forward.
And if we have a
zero here then it's
already zero in the next
one and we don't have to do,
that would be the
second pivot row,
we don't have to
subtract it from this row
because a zero is already there.
So we like zeroes.
And sparse matrices
have a lot of them.
But we only like them if
they're in the right place.
And what's the right place?
It's, roughly speaking,
it's the beginning of a row.
So we're very happy
with, we would
like to get an ordering that
looks somehow like this.
We would like to get a
bunch of zeroes in there.
Well that's, I
really overdid it.
Maybe we can't get that many.
But my point is,
you see the point
that those are at the
beginning of the rows.
So let's say we can't quite
get to that, but maybe
something more like that.
Zero.
So we get some rows starting
with zeroes and then we get
rows that don't.
Which of course, I mean, they
were there in the first place.
What we've done is move
them to the bottom.
And the reason for
moving them to the bottom
is that they don't
destroy rows below them.
Yeah.
I didn't show how
that would happen.
Suppose I had a number there.
Suppose that wasn't a zero.
And all these were.
Then when I do that elimination
I subtract a multiple
of that row from this row.
Do you see that those
zeroes will fill in?
So fill in is the bad thing
that you're trying to avoid.
So in this quick
discussion of reordering
you're trying to order the rows
so that they start with zeroes
for as long as you can because
those zeroes will never
fill in.
Zeroes inside a band, yes,
just to make the point again,
suppose I have a long row.
Then if I have some zeroes
here, here, here, useless.
Because when I go to do
elimination on these rows, when
I subtract a multiple of
that row from that row,
that zero will fill in,
it didn't help, it's gone.
And this and this.
So zeroes sort of
near the diagonal
are often going to fill in.
It's zeroes at the far
left that are good.
So that's a discussion
of a topic that
actually comes into 18.086.
And so does the third words
that I thought I would just
write on the board.
So this would be topic
specializing in how do you
solve large systems.
And reordering with
elimination is one way.
And a second approach is, I
just put these words up here
so that you've seen them.
Conjugate gradient
method, that's
a giant success in solving
symmetric problems.
Large symmetric problems.
Something called multigrid
is a terrific, incomplete LU.
People have worked hard on ideas
for solving problems so large
that this becomes too expensive.
But backslash is
the natural choice.
If you can do it, it's
like it's so simple.
So let me focus on backslash.
So backslash is the
key to talk about.
Let me see, let's just think
what does backslash do?
Suppose I had two equations,
two different right-hand sides,
b and c with the same matrix
A. Would I solve them,
would I do u=A\b and
then separately A\c?
No.
If I had two equations
with the same matrix,
there's a big saving in, suppose
I have two equations, two,
well, can I put it?
I'll make a matrix.
I mean this is what
MATLAB would always do.
Put those two right-hand
sides into a matrix.
Then backslash is
happy with that.
That backslash command
would solve both equations.
It would give you the
answer then, would be,
it would be two parts to it.
What would be the
first column of u then?
So, do you see what I have now?
I have a square matrix
A times an unknown u.
And I've got two
right-hand sides.
The point is this often happens.
If you're doing, say,
a design problem.
You might try different designs.
So those different designs give
you different right-hand sides.
And then you have
a problem to solve.
What's the response
to those designs?
What are the displacements,
what happens?
So you want to solve
with two right-hand sides
and the point is you don't want
to go through the elimination
process on A twice.
That's crazy.
You see how that
elimination process on A
has this, what I described
here, didn't look at b.
I didn't even get to the
right-hand side part.
I was dealing with the expensive
part, which is the matrix A.
So we don't want to
pay that price twice.
And therefore backslash
is all set up.
So what's the first
column of u then?
It's A\b.
And now what's
another way to write,
a more mathematical
way to write A?
What's the answer to Au=b.
It's u equals A
inverse b, right?
That's the answer
in the first column
and A inverse c would be the
answer in the second column.
So it would produce
those answers.
Backslash will
produce the answer
to the first equation and the
answer the second equation.
Will it do that by
finding A inverse?
No.
A inverse, for
multiple reasons, we
don't often compute,
if it's 3 by 3, 4 by 4,
then it's not a bad idea to
see what A inverse looks like.
We'll do that
actually, because it's
very enlightening if
the matrix is small,
you can see what's going on.
But for a large problem
we don't want A inverse.
We want the answer.
And backslash goes
to the answer.
It doesn't get there
by computing A inverse.
And our examples will show how.
So I'm giving A inverse a
little bad comments right now.
So I maybe should
finish that sentence
and then you'll
see me turn around
and compute the darn thing.
But why do we not use A inverse?
Two reasons.
One is it's more expensive.
If I have to compute A
inverse and multiply by b,
that's taking too long.
Second reason is A inverse could
easily be a full, dense matrix.
All non-zero.
Where A itself was
like, tridiagonal.
So if A is tridiagonal,
all the numbers we need
are there in three diagonals,
we don't want A inverse,
you'll see, A inverse is full.
So two reasons for
not using A inverse.
Takes too long in the first
place even in the good case
and often our matrix
A has got lots
of zeroes that are not there in
A inverse so we've wasted time.
Nevertheless let
me say something
about A inverse
on the next board.
I don't know if you ever thought
about the inverse matrix.
Let me ask you this question.
Suppose I use the command
A\I. What's that doing?
That's putting the identity
on the right-hand side
instead of a single
vector b or instead
of two vectors b and
c I'm now putting n.
That's okay.
Backslash will work with that.
That's a shorthand for solving.
This solves all these equations.
A, it'll get my different
answers, u_1, u_2.
It'll get n different answers
from the n right-hand sides,
the columns of I. Let
me take to be three.
0, 1, 0; 0, 0, 1.
But I'll take n to be three.
That's the identity.
So this solves that equation.
A\I will output
u, will output u.
And here's the question.
What have I got?
If you have a matrix A,
square matrix and of course
you have to create I as
eye(3), that I would be,
this would be eye(3).
Cleve Moler's lousy pun.
So what would I get?
What would I get?
The inverse, yes.
I'd get the inverse.
I'd get the inverse matrix.
A backslash-- why's that?
Because what matrix
solves, what's
the solution u to A
times something equal I?
The solution to--
This equation is Au=I.
The solution to that equation
is the inverse matrix.
u will be A inverse.
So that is a pretty,
I mean, that's pretty,
if I wanted A inverse
that's a good way to do it.
Other ways to do it
would be inv(A) in MATLAB
and other ways, but this is
about as good as you get.
Do you see that you get the
inverse matrix that way?
And it's worth giving
some words to that fact.
How would I describe this?
This is a set of three
different problems.
I would describe [1, 0, 0], that
right-hand side, as an impulse.
That's an impulse.
A delta vector with an impulse
in the first component.
I'd call that an impulse
in the second component.
in the third component.
So my inputs are three
impulses and my outputs
are u_1, u_2, u_3.
What words might I use?
I could call those
impulse response.
If I were in Course
6, I certainly would.
These would be impulses,
these would be the responses
to that impulse from our system.
So those are impulse responses
but in linear algebra
the words I would
use, u_1, u_2, u_3
are the columns of
A inverse, right?
That's what we just
said. u_1, u_2, u_3.
So the columns of--
Let me write that down.
The columns of A inverse
are the responses,
the u's, the solutions to
the impulses, to n impulses.
And these are the
columns of I. Do you see?
Nothing I've said so
far is deep or anything.
But it's just, this
comes up so much
that it's nice to have different
ways to think about this.
And actually, yeah, if
I had to solve by hand,
if I had to find the inverse
by hand I would use elimination
on this system of equations.
I would take A and put
the identity next to it.
I would do elimination a lot.
Actually I'll put that in one.
If I had to find the inverse I
would take this block matrix.
Is that the first block
matrix we've seen?
Block matrices are really,
you should just get familiar,
when you're getting
familiar with matrices,
they often come in blocks.
So here's a three
by three block,
here's a three by three
block, the whole matrix
is three by six.
I can go through the
elimination steps on it.
If I really go
haywire on elimination
and keep going and going and
going all the way until A gets
to the identity,
so I do elimination
and I get it triangular
then I even clean out up
above the pivots and then I
change all the pivots to one,
I can get all the
way to the identity
if the matrix is invertible.
And what do you think will
show up in the right half?
A inverse, yeah.
So A inverse will show up there.
So in 18.06 I would
explain, go through examples
of this computation just
to see A inverse appear.
There's no reason for us
to go through long examples
like that.
Maybe one three by three
would be worth doing,
but in the big picture we're
going to use backslash.
Questions or discussion.
So this is the sort of overall
picture about the inverse.
Well this is about the inverse.
This was about elimination.
I've gotta take a little
time on elimination.
No it's just too important.
It's sort of straightforward
and mechanical
but it's like, too
important to blow away.
So let me remove that and
put something better there.
So now I'm talking
about elimination.
I'm talking about one equation.
I'm back to Au=b.
Au=b.
And notice I'm using the
letter A rather than K or one
of our special letters
because right now I don't know
that that's a special matrix.
In a minute the
example I do will
be one of our special
matrices of course,
and then I'll use its letter.
Just a word, though.
I thought I would take-- you're
getting a lot of big picture
here for a minute and then
we'll get into the details.
I thought I would
just, like, this
is an occasion to look ahead.
To say a word about the big
picture of linear algebra.
It's got four major
problems, linear algebra.
And there are four commands
to solve those problems.
And those commands,
why not know?
So those commands are: lu.
I'm speaking about MATLAB
notation but Octave, Scilab,
Python, R, all other
would have those.
Would do these same things.
So lu is the command
that produces this,
but I didn't say
what that is yet.
Ooh.
So that's my job, right.
What does this mean?
What's up there?
So, okay, to nobody's
surprise MATLAB thought, okay,
lu was a good letter for that.
And what did MATLAB think of as
a good letter for the command
that does this? qr.
So if I did lu(A) or qr(A)
I would get-- I mean,
this is sometimes associated
with the names of Gram-Schmidt.
It makes vectors orthogonal.
Not to worry about this stuff.
You can like, close your
eyes for a moment here.
lu is the first command and
that's what today's about.
qr is the key command for
least squares problems.
Maybe the biggest application
of rectangular matrices,
I'm sure that's the big.
Eigenvalues, do you
know about eigenvalues?
Well we'll just name
the command eig(A).
And the singular
value decomposition,
which you may never have heard
of, but you will, is svd(A).
Can I leave that?
It's in the videotape now.
And my point is that when
we've spoken about those four,
we really have got
numerical linear algebra
and a lot of pure linear
algebra explained.
These are the four big ones.
And I guess what I'm
saying is, the four
big problems of linear algebra
turn out to, a good way
to describe the answer is as
a factorization of the matrix.
This is a factor.
So now let me say
what this one is.
I start with a matrix and
what elimination is really
doing, if you look to
see what is it doing,
it's producing a
lower triangular
times an upper triangular.
Let's go directly to that.
Let me go directly to that.
Let me take an example.
So here's my matrix.
Well, I don't have to call it
A because you recognize it.
So what's our name
for that matrix?
T. T because the top
boundary condition is free.
Oh, that reminds me.
Some good comments after class
Friday brought out something
that I sloughed over.
That the free-fixed matrix,
the free-fixed problem
is usually one unknown
larger than the fixed-fixed.
Because remember the fixed-fixed
problem had both ends fixed.
They were not unknowns.
The only unknowns were one,
two, three to n in the middle.
But people noticed when I was
talking about the free boundary
condition that u_0 came into
it and u_0 is not known.
So really, the free
boundary condition like,
has an extra unknown, an extra
row and column in the matrix
and that's correct.
We'll see later in
Fourier transforms
cosine matrices are one size
bigger than sine matrices.
The cosine matrices
are free-free
and the sine matrices
are fixed-fixed.
And now here we're
at free-fixed.
I want to do elimination
on that matrix.
And while I'm at it,
we'll find the inverse.
But let's do elimination.
Just on that matrix.
Just to see what this
L and U stuff is.
What do we do?
The first pivot is?
One, it's fine.
Not going to worry about that.
We'll use it now.
So how do I use it?
I use a pivot, now
listen because here
is a convention here, I'm
going to use the word subtract.
You would say add that
row to that row, right?
Because you want
to get a zero here.
Forgive me for making
it sound harder.
I'm going to say subtract
because I like subtraction.
Subtract minus one of
that row, my multiplier
is minus one here.
I'm going to say subtract minus
one of that row from that.
Same thing.
You'll say okay.
No problem.
Let's just do it.
So there's the pivot row and
now when I-- shall I just add?
When I add that to that, or
as my superego is saying,
subtract minus one
of that from that.
What do I get?
I get the zero, the
one and the minus one.
And then what do I get?
What's the multiplier?
So let's just put these l,
these multipliers, the l_(2, 1).
That's the multiplier.
2, 1 refers to row
two, column one.
And this step got the zero
in row two, column one.
And what was the
multiplier that did it?
It's the number that I
multiplied row one by
and subtracted from row
two, so it was minus one.
What's l_(3,1)?
What's the multiplier that
produces a zero in the three,
row three, column one position?
It's zero.
I take zero of this
row away from this row
because it's zero already.
So I'm not going to change, that
row won't change and l_(3,1)
was zero.
Now I know the next pivot.
I'm ready to use it.
I want to get a zero
below it because I'm
aiming at this
upper triangular U.
And what's the multiplier now?
And what's its number?
What's the multiplier number?
3, 2 because I'm trying to
fix row three, column two.
And what do I multiply
this by and subtract
from this to make it zero?
It's negative one again.
negative one, right.
It's negative one.
Sorry.
Right.
And now what happens
when I do that?
Can I just do it in place here?
Forgive me if I just
add that to that.
And I'll get zero and one.
And now what do I know at this
point, what have I learned?
The most important
thing I've learned
is the matrix is invertible.
Because the pivots
one, one, and one,
well they're all
here on the diagonal.
This is my matrix U. That's
my upper triangular matrix.
And-- yeah, of course?
I'm subtracting
from this, so I've
got the two is there,
yeah, yeah, that's right.
So the two is sitting there
and I'm subtracting minus one
of that row from it and that
would mean taking, yeah, yeah.
Right.
That would mean I'm
subtracting one from the two
and getting the one.
Yeah, yeah.
So the row, the
typical entry is,
the typical result is:
the row you have minus
l times the pivot row.
The row you have minus the
multiplier times the pivot row.
That's the operation that
elimination lives on.
Elimination does
that all the time.
It's one of the basic
linear algebra subroutines.
B L A S.
Now, this is my U. So that's
the goal of elimination,
get it upper triangular.
And the reason is, you can solve
upper triangular systems really
fast.
These multipliers l, l_(2,1),
and so on, they and go
into the L matrix.
And now, let me just say
it here that in a way,
that example is too beautiful.
Seldom am I sorry to see an
example come out beautifully,
but why do I say this
is too beautiful?
It's not typical.
If I had other numbers here, I
would get to other numbers here
and what would be the
difference, typically?
The pivots wouldn't be all ones.
That's what's too beautiful
here, but let's go with it.
I mean, it was worth it because
everything came out simple.
But the pivots for
another problem, ooh,
let me just do a
second problem here.
I'll do the fixed-fixed guy.
Okay, so let's just do
elimination on that.
That's the first pivot.
Subtract.
Now what's the multiplier now?
You're not as quick as MATLAB.
MATLAB is ahead of you.
So the multiplier is -1/2.
So the multiplier
is, l_(2,1) is -1/2.
l_(3,1) will again be
zero and let's use it,
so it knocks that guys out.
And what did that
number come out to be?
Do you remember?
That was 3/2.
I think we looked at that once.
And that would be all the same.
And then the next multiplier,
l_(3,2) will be negative 2/3
because when I multiply that
by 2/3 it gives me the negative
one and then I subtract and
it kills this and I get 4/3.
I just did that quickly.
And my main point was the
pivots are on the diagonal.
They're not all ones now.
So this is a more typical one.
This is, again our U.
And our L matrix will be,
oh, oh, that's the point.
That these l's,
these multipliers
fit right into a lower
triangular matrix.
All these multipliers,
and we'll put ones
on the diagonal of that guy
and these lower triangular ones
will fit in just right
perfectly in there.
Over here the L would be,
let me construct the L.
Ones on the diagonal
representing
the pivot rows that stayed
put and minus one, zero,
and minus one as the multipliers
that-- So this was L,
the multipliers that we used.
One more.
We're doing lots of good
stuff here and it's not deep,
but it's-- Suppose the
matrix had been singular.
We have to realize, okay, this
elimination method is great.
But it can break down and
it's going to break down,
it has to break down somehow
if the matrix is singular.
Now what's our example of
a singular matrix here?
The matrix, this is free-fixed
and that by fixing one
support it wasn't singular,
but if I want to make it
singular, what'll I take?
Free-free.
Free-free matrix.
So can I, if I had thought
to bring colored chalk,
I'll just erase for a
moment for the bad case.
The bad case would be free-free.
And how would it show up
as bad in elimination.
How does a singular
matrix reveal itself
as elimination goes forward?
Because you can't
tell at the beginning.
What would have gone wrong?
We would have had a zero there.
We had a two that
dropped to one.
But if we start with a
one, it'll drop to zero.
That would have
been a zero there.
The matrix would not
have had three pivots.
This upper triangular
matrix is singular, no good.
And that tells us back there
that the original matrix
is singular, no good.
So if I can't get to
three pivots somehow,
the matrix'll be singular and
that's an example that is.
And MATLAB would immediately
tell us, of course.
So let's go back to the good
case for the main point.
The good case for
the main point.
So the good case
was three pivots.
In fact it was extra
good because they all
turned out to be ones.
Now, oh, now we're ready for LU.
Here's the magic.
And I'm not giving a proof.
The magic is that the result
U, if I multiply the multiplier
matrix L times
the result U, I'll
bring back A. I'll bring
back A. So let me just see.
If I multiply L by U, so
this is now L times U,
maybe you can see that
I get A. So what is U?
I just have to copy it.
[1, 1,  1; -1, -1, 0].
I could fill in the zeroes
but I know they're there.
That's L times U.
And sure enough,
if I do the multiplication,
this-- How would
you to that multiplication?
I would say this is one of
the first row when I see that.
1, 0, 0 multiplying these.
I'd say get one
of the first row.
That's correct in A. Here I
would say this is minus one
of the first row, plus
one of the second row,
and sure enough it's
the right part of A.
And this is minus one
of the second row,
plus one of the third row,
and sure enough it's the right
third row of A. I get A. And
that's when elimination goes
through with no zero
pivots, no problems,
just a bunch of multipliers,
then that wonderful description
of it, A=LU is correct.
I don't know how
many that's new to.
I should maybe
have thought ahead.
How many have seen
like, L times U before?
Just to give me an idea?
Quite a few.
Okay.
So it's terrific.
Oh, here I would
get L times U. Now
this is like a little more
interesting because the pivots
were not ones.
So that's my matrix U. And
here's my matrix L, right?
Okay, big point.
Because we're so interested in
symmetric matrices and this one
in particular, or that one,
symmetric matrices are good.
Now, I'm unhappy
about one aspect.
So now there's just
one part of this.
This was great, we got three
non-zero pivots, we got to U,
we got the multiplier
matrix all fine
and we would be ready
for the right-hand side
for two right-hand sides,
we would even be ready for
all three right-hand sides,
whatever.
But I have one criticism.
The matrix A which was
our K, this was really K,
was symmetric.
That was the very first
thing you did, told me
on the very first day.
And now it's equal to L
times U, but what's happened?
The symmetry is lost.
Somehow the L has
ones on the diagonal,
the U as we have it has
pivots on the diagonal,
now the pivots are not all ones.
So you see the symmetry
of the problem got lost,
and that shouldn't happen.
And there ought to
be a way to get back.
Okay.
And now I want to describe the
way to get back to symmetry.
So LU doesn't keep the symmetry.
L has ones, U has pivots.
Different.
But a very simple idea will
bring back the symmetry.
That is peel off the pivots
into a diagonal matrix.
In other words,
there's a matrix,
I'll call it D, D for diagonal.
I'll divide those
numbers out of each row.
And can I just do that?
So I'm just going
to write this U
as a product of this
diagonal D where I'm going
to be dividing the two out.
So when I divide the
two out from that row
I'm left with 1, -1/2, 0.
And when I divide
3/2, the pivot then,
it makes that pivot
into a one and what
does it produce for that guy?
When I divide 3/2, when I divide
that -1 by 3/2, what do I get?
I get negative, division will
be 2/3, I'll get a negative 2/3.
And now, on the last row I'm
dividing that row by 4/3.
When I divide that row by
4/3, what row do I get here?
[0, 0, 1].
Because I've made the pivots
one, well they're not pivots.
What I've done is
separate out the pivots.
So I've made the diagonal ones
just by separating it out.
And what's happened?
My goal was to get
back some symmetry that
was there at the start.
Now so I have a pivot matrix
D, and what's that matrix?
You could say,
well, it's the rest.
But that's not what
I'm looking for.
What is it?
Can everybody have a look at it?
I can't raise it.
If you look at what we
got there, what is it?
What's the right
name to give it?
L transpose, exactly!
That's the right name.
L transpose.
So what am I concluding then?
I'm concluding that, let's
see, where shall I put this?
And it'll come back to it.
Well, here we had just to
show it wasn't an accident,
here we had L L
transpose and what
was the pivot matrix in this
too beautiful problem case?
It was the identity.
So we didn't notice it.
So can I squeeze
in the identity?
That's the pivot matrix there.
But and again, we had
L times L transpose.
The beauty was there,
the symmetry was there.
And now what's the usual thing?
So really I'm completing
this to one more thought.
In that case when
A is symmetric.
I'm completing, I have the
L. I'm factoring out the D.
And what's left is L transpose.
I hope you like LDL^T.
Seeing a matrix on one side
and the transpose
on the other side,
the matrix L at the left and L
transpose at the right is just
right.
So the point of
symmetric case we have,
and I'll use the
letter K rather than A
because now we're getting the
matrix that's more special.
It's that K or
it's this T or it's
any other symmetric matrix.
The elimination leads
to, uses multipliers L
and if I factor out
the pivot matrix
then the other part
is L transpose.
We've seen that just by example.
By two examples.
Now I want to just look at that.
Because this that describes not
only the result of elimination
which is the key operation,
but it also keeps the symmetry.
In fact every matrix of
that sort is symmetric.
No, yeah, that's important.
This is sure to be symmetric.
We will often see matrices
multiplied by their transpose.
So what I'm saying is
that if you gave me
any matrix L, any diagonal
matrix D, and then
the transpose of L, if
I multiplied those out,
I would get a symmetric matrix.
And going the other way, if I
started with a symmetric matrix
and I did elimination
and got an L,
then the D factoring out
would leave me L transpose.
So what you've
seen by example is
what will happen all the time.
Now why is that
matrix symmetric?
Here we get a chance to show
the power of matrix notation,
really.
I just think that if I have
any matrix L, in this case
it happened to be lower
triangular, but if I have
any matrix L and I have a
nice, symmetric diagonal guy
in the middle and I
have the transpose
of this matrix on
the other side I
think the result is a symmetric
matrix when I multiply.
So it's these symmetric
factorizations
that we're getting to and
are important problems
because our important
problems are symmetric.
Ok, why is that sure
to be symmetric?
Suppose I asked
you as a exercise,
prove that L times a diagonal
times L transpose is always
a symmetric matrix.
How could you do that?
You could certainly create
an example that did it
and check it out,
multiply, it would work.
But we want to see that this
is going to be true always.
So how would you do that?
I guess, let me get started.
I would take its transpose.
If I want to show
something's symmetric,
I transpose it and see if I
get the same matrix again.
So let me take the
transpose of this.
So I'm answering, Why is
it sure to be symmetric?
So let me take K transpose.
So this is the
transpose of, I have
K equals something times
something times something,
A times B times
C, you could say.
If I transpose a
matrix, how can I
create transposes
out of A, B and C.
Do you remember what happens?
They reverse the order.
It's like inverses.
Transposes and inverses
both have that key rule.
When you have a product
and you invert it,
they come in the opposite order.
When you transpose it, they
come in the opposite order.
So let me try put these
separate transposes
in the opposite order.
So I've used the most
important fact there.
Which is just a fact about
transposing a product.
Okay, what have I got now?
What's L transpose transposed?
It's L, great.
What's L transpose L transposed?
Nothing but L. Transpose
twice and I'm back to L.
What about D transpose?
Same as D. Because D was
symmetric, in fact diagonal.
So what have I learned?
The proof is done.
I've got K back again.
This was the original K. So I've
learned that K transpose is K.
So you're going to
see time after time,
let me just put
these things there,
you're going to see an A
transpose times an A. That's
the most important, most highly
important multiplication.
Take a matrix,
maybe rectangular,
multiply by A transpose.
So this matrix is
certainly square
because A could be m by n.
And then A transpose
would be n by m
and the result would be n by n.
So it's certainly square.
But now what's the new
property we now know?
It's symmetric.
It's symmetric because
if I transpose it,
the transpose of A
will go on this side,
the double transpose
but the double transpose
is A again, so symmetric.
So I'm plugging away here
on symmetric matrices
because they're just-- yeah,
what does symmetry mean in,
yeah, can I just come back
to this idea of responses?
And by the way, if
this was symmetric,
would its inverse be symmetric?
The answer is yes.
If a matrix is symmetric,
its inverse is symmetric.
These symmetric matrices
are a fantastic family.
So I could add that to this.
K inverse will also symmetric
without having yet said why.
But maybe in words, I'll
just say a few words here
at the end.
So what's a typical entry?
Say the (2, 1) entry, just to
carry on with this language one
more moment.
This is A inverse here.
Now the (2, 1)
entry in the inverse
is an impulse is in the first,
the first mass, whatever
gets an impulse.
And that is the response
of the second mass.
The response in position two
to the impulse in position one.
Now my matrix is
symmetric, thinking
about symmetric matrices here.
So what about here?
Here, if I take the
impulse in position two
and look at the response
in position one,
so do you see the difference?
In general, those
could be different.
This is the response at position
two to an impulse at one.
This is the response at
one to an impulse at two.
You see that I'm
multiplying those columns
and getting these columns.
And what's the point
about symmetry?
Those are the same.
Symmetry is expressing
this physical meaning
that the response at
i, to an impulse at j
is the same as the response
at j to an impulse at i.
And that's sort of, that's
such an important property,
you want to notice it.
And it goes into symmetry.
So many, many problems will be
symmetric and then some won't.
We'll have to admit this
won't cover everything,
but it covers such an
important and beautiful part.
So that's today's lecture
on LU elimination,
solving linear
systems, and then let's
move forward to understanding
the actual inverses.